الى الضفه الغربيه الان حيث شهدت مدينه
نابلس مواجهات بين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها المدينه لتامين
دخول مستوطنين الى قبر يوسف الليله
الماضيه كما قال المركز الفلسطيني للاعلام
ان مقاومين فلسطينيين خاضوا فجر اليوم
الاربعاء اشتباكات مسلحه مع قوات خاصه من
الجيش الاسرائيلي عقب اقتحامها مدينه
طوباس وان الجيش الاسرائيلي ارسل تعزيزات
لمساعده القوات الخاصه على الانسحاب كما
اعتقلت قوته الاحتلال 13
من الضفه الغربيه الليله الماضيه وفجر
اليوم وقالت هيئه شؤون الاسرى ان قوات
الاحتلال نفذت الحمله في مدن جنين
وقلقيليا ونابلس والبيره وجار نقل جميع
المعتقلين الى مراكز الاعتقال للتحقيق
معهم بتهم مقاومه الاحتلال
اعلنت سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه عن
اجراءات امنيه وعسكريه لحمايه مسيره
الاعلام التي تنظمها مجموعات يمينيه في
ذكرى احتلال اسرائيل للقدس الشرقيه وضمها
وفق التقويم العبري يوم غد الخميس وخشدت
الشرطه واجهزه الامن المختلفه نحو ثلاثه
الاف وثلا من قواتها لتامين مسار
المشاركين في المسيره والتي اعلن رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو انها ستتم وفق ما
هو مخطط لها وفي نفس المسار المقرر كما
اعلن ان الجيش الاسرائيلي عن اتخاذ
اجراءات على طول الحدود مع قطاع غزه
ولبنان ورفع حاله التاهب وفي قوته
وتعزيزها بمنظومات القبه الحديديه
من رام الله مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البديريه مع نادي لنا ايضا اخر هذه
التطورات
بالطبع التطورات كما
ذكرت حقا عمليات الاقتحامات والاعتقالات
لم توقف
بالضفه الغربيه تم اعتقال ما يزيد على
ثلاثه عشر فلسطينيين من مناطق عده ابرزها
كانت في سيره الحارثيه وقريه اليمون قضاء
جنين ايضا كان هناك وتاكيد ايضا من قبل
قوات الاحتلال اشتباك مسلح في منطقه
الطوباس ايضا خلال محاوله وحده خاصه من
المستعربين اقتحام المدينه لاعتقالي
فلسطينيين كشف امرها
فقامت قوات الاحتلال بتعزيز وجودها
العسكري وتم اطلاق النار والاشتباكات
المسلحه ولكن بالطبع كان الحدث الابرز هو
ليله امس وفجر هذا اليوم في منطقه قبر
يوسف في المنطقه الشرقيه لمدينه نابلس حيث
قامت قواتها الاحتلال بازاله بدايه كل
السواتر الترابيه التي كانت قد وضعها
الفلسطينيون لمنع دخول المست الى القبر
اللي اداء طقوس دينيه قوات الاحتلال اطلقت
الرصاص المعدني بكثافه وايضا قنابل الغاز
وفق وزاره الصحه والهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
اصيب على الاقل ثلاثه فلسطينيين بالرصاص
المعدني وعشرات الفلسطينيين الاخرين
اصيبوا بحالات اختراق ايضا كان عدد من
المقاومين الفلسطينيين قد اشتبكوا مع قوات
الاحتلال بالسلاح ولم يعلن عن اصابات اما
بالطبع كل الانظار الان تتجه صوب مدينه
القدس التي في هذه الاثناء تجرى فيها
جرافات وتقوم جرافات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بهدم منزل في بلده سلوان ولكن الانظار
تتجه الى هناك بعد التاكيد على ان المدينه
بدات تتحول الى سكنه عسكريه في محيط
البلده القديمه وداخل البلده ومحيط المسجد
الاقصى المبارك الحكومه
اوعظت بتعزيز التواجد العسكري اكثر من
3300 عنصر امن سيتواجدون منذ صباح يوم غد
الخميس قبيل الاستعدادات
لمسيره المستوطنين التي اكد بنفسه رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه نتنياهو انها ستسير
وفق الجدول المخطط لها اي الدخول الى
الحقيقه الاسلامي والسير في كل شوارع
البلده القديمه بالطبع كل عام هذه المسيره
تشكل يعني حدث بارز وحدث يدلل على خطوره
الوضع في مدينه القدس التي يمكن ان تشعل
الوضع برمته قوات الاحتلال ايضا عززت من
وجودها ومن القبه الحديديه على طول خط
الحدود مع قطاع غزه وايضا على الحدود مع
لبنان خشيه قيام عناصر المقاومه
الفلسطينيه باطلاق صواريخ خلال
المسيره التي ستحلم تحمل فيها الاع لام
الاسرائيليه
والاستفزازات التي كنا قد رايناها على
مدار الاعوام الماضيه والاعتداء على
الفلسطينيين
والمقدسيين بالطبع هذه المسيره تاتي وفق
التقويم العبري في ذكرى احتلال الشاطره
الشرقي من مدينه القدس المحتله شكرا لك
كنت معنا من رام الله